[Musique]
tu fais de couches et la voilà à quoi je
dois vas-y ouais bon bois tu fais ce que
tu veux
moi je dit bonsoir bonsoir
permettez moi de vous présenter aux
puces c'est un
un chien croisé border collie et
labrador de 11 ans et demi ce qui fait à
peu près 84 ans en âge humain
alors je vous donne d'emblée toute ces
ces précisions
parce que je sais très bien comment ça
se passe un autrement c'est ben comment
tu t'appelles comment tu t'appelles je
peux qu'adresser au petit bourg toi tu
puta je peux te caresser et c'est comme
ça dix fois par jour à leurs débuts on
trouve ça sympa rires les gens sont
quand même gentil et à la longue mais ça
tape sur le système
c'est vraiment épouvantable et puis
surtout c'est très curieuse qu'on parle
aux chiens
mais moi transparente je n'existe pas
quand je me suis quand même un peu
interrogé sur ce phénomène bizarre je me
dis mais bon c'est vrai on met d'accord
c'est le chien le plus extraordinaire de
la terre c'est mon chien
mais bon si on a quand même un tout
petit peu d'objectivité
c'est quand même un chien standard alors
pourquoi vouloir absolument le toucher
est-ce qu'il a des pouvoirs thaumaturge
est-ce qu'il est magique
alors je me suis posé des questions et
mon interprétation alors toute
personnelle qui n'engage que moi c'est
que le chien prêtant ses yeux à la règle
il ya plus d'un bug est la preuve
il disparaît donc il ya plus besoin de
s'en préoccuper
il ya plein de l'aider et surtout il
n'est plus inquiétant il ne ramène plus
à cette terreur ancestrale des ténèbres
d'autant plus que beaucoup de détenteurs
de chiens guides accréditent cette idée
à mon chien fait mes yeux
ben non en ça ça m'agace alors ton chien
c'est ton chien c'est pas un robot
c'est un chien mais c'est vrai toute
l'imagerie populaire à ceux ci toujours
l'handicapé de la vue et le chien
ah les copains comme on passe le savent
bien qu est-ce qu on ne cesse de leur
casser les pieds pourquoi t'as pas tiens
ben pourquoi t'as pas de chien ça
atteindrait quand même
ben oui mais pourtant dans la réalité il
y à 325 mille déficients visuels en
suisse et seulement 350 chiens guides
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement peu je
vous laisse faire le calcul de
pourcentage justement les chiffres
patron truc alors vous penserez
peut-être que c'est particulièrement
difficile pour en avoir à 1 bat pas du
tout 1 il suffit d'être déficients
visuels bien sûr ça fait quand même un
peu obligé ensuite il faut quand même en
bonne santé pour être capable de
s'occuper du chien c'est normal et puis
un minimum un minimum de sens de
l'orientation
il ya quatre écoles de chiens guides ont
suis donc ya pas vraiment de pénurie
c'est entre 3 et 8 mois pour en avoir un
seulement il ya deux autres condition
sinequanone c'est qu'il faut aimer les
chiens faut avoir envie de vivre avec
elle surtout il faut avoir deux heures
par jour pour s'en occuper
s'en occuper pardon et puis pour qu'ils
travaillent le chien doit être heureux
donc il faut vraiment être dans une
relation optimum avec ses chiens parce
que lui il va pas travailler pour ses
cotisations en retraite ils sont fous
complètement
ils travaillent vraiment parce qu'il a
envie de faire plaisir oui bah oui bah
oui je sais je vous entends un je vous
entends audit mais elle est bien gentil
la petite dame c'est bien intéressant
tout ce qu'il raconte mais pas du tout
dans le thème
je sais bien je sais bien mais c'est que
je me casse la tête depuis des jours
pour me dire mais comment est ce que je
peux faire comprendre ce qui se passe
quand un chien quand tout d'un coup on
se retrouve avec ce chien
ce chien qui est toute une histoire
avant nous on se connaît pas il est il
va naître dans son élevage à quatre mois
et demi il va devoir quitter sa main sa
maman chien comme tous les chiens et il
va aller dans une famille d'accueil
pendant une année alors je profite quand
même de tirer un grand coup de chapeau à
ces gens parce que ils vont prendre ce
petit chiot ils vont nous apprendre la
propreté toutes les lèves les zones là
l'éducation de base et puis l'emmener
dans plein d'endroits différents pour
qu'ils soient pas qu'ils soient pas trop
peureux puis quand le chien devient
enfin agréable à vivre et bien ils
doivent leur redonner à l'école est là
le chien ben il va plus du tout avoir de
vie de famille et après une sélection
assez drastiques buy va commencer son
apprentissage de chiens guides avec un
instructeur ou une instructrice et puis
ça va prendre encore une année et puis
là deux nouveaux une séparation puis
pouf il arrive à la maison et bon moi
j'avais de la chance j'avais d'autres
chiens avant mais son nom n'a jamais eu
vous voyez pas ne serait que pour
apprendre à ramasser les crottes sans
mettre les pieds dedans je peux vous
dire que c'est pas simple et puis c'est
un truc extrêmement bizarre que de se
dire qu'on va faire confiance à un
animal d'accord il est censé vous mois
voire mieux que nous mais quand même ils
voient pour les couleurs il a pas le
même champ visuel c'est pas si simple
mais enfin bon vu qu'on est là on est là
donc on va commencer à se déplacer est
le chien il faut en plus apprendre à
donner tous les ordres au bon moment et
les ordres il y en a quand même une
quinzaine une trentaine à apprendre
alors si ni gauche d'être à droite ce
cas-là trouver un escalier je vais pas
vous faire les 30 rassurez vous c'est un
italien parce que c'est une longue et
plus sonore que le français est moins
dure qu'elle allemand et puis surtout
celles handicapées de la vue qui apprend
la langue du chien comme ça on peut
remettre le chien partout sans tenir
compte de la langue du du détenteur
alors voilà on a un carnet dans la main
et puis il faut parce que c'est bien le
pour que ce soit clair un seul
déficients visuels qui dirige le chien
le chien est un éditeur d'obstacles et
alors là les obstacles un croyez moi
y'en a scellé les poteaux mal placé vos
voitures toujours garées sur les
trottoirs pour deux minutes mais on
passe toujours à ce moment là faille en
a partout et puis alors la plaie de ces
dernières années l'obstacle que même le
chien de la peine à éviter c'est le
piéton
l'oeil rivé sur son smartphone qui vous
percute de plein fouet qu'il faut faire
mais vous pouvez pas regarder en vo
aller désolé je peux pas alors par
contre le smartphone laissé un gros
avantage pour nous c'est maintenant avec
le gps on va pouvoir aller dans des
endroits qu'on connaît pas il suffit de
prendre le gps de transmettre de
traduire qu en quelque sorte l'ordre au
chien est flou chiens et on va pouvoir
aller dans un endroit inconnu
ce qu'on pouvait pas tellement faire
avant ça c'est génial alors voici bas je
reviens
voilà ce premier jour et puis voilà on
apprend à donner les ormes on apprend à
se faire confiance
le chien commence à comprendre qu'il va
rester chez vous il ya le lien qui
commence à se faire
et puis un beau jour tout à coup se rend
compte que c'est facile mais ce harnais
qu'on a dans la main ce vraiment mais
souple agréable on sent l'énergie du
chien le chien a même plus besoin de
donner les ordres et comprend avant
qu'on lui parle ça devient lia c'est
magique
et puis là tout d'un coup on se rend
compte qu'on n'est plus un individu est
un chien qui marche on mais qu'on est
vraiment ensemble on est un tandem une
entité et on est exactement complices
dans la même énergie
alors c'est vrai que moi je me sens un
peu particulière l'aco plus parce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure qui
connaissait pas son détenteur
monfette lui il m a choisi ce que
j'étais allé faire un reportage dans son
école et dès qu'il m'a vu il y en ait
plus que pour moi c'était j'ai à peine
pu travailler c'était et je te ramène le
bâton et puis un petit coup de patte
parce que je veux que tu me qu'un rêve
il y en a que pour moi et puis quand on
m'a téléphoné quelques mois prendra tu
sais touche institué est toujours libre
j'ai craqué j'ai craqué puis j'ai dit
oui voilà et puis moi ils s'arrêtaient
pourquoi il fallait un petit peu quand
même être solide pour prendre cet animal
qui way s'il était humain ce sera un
aspect rien il est il est hyper doué
dans son domaine aux puces on va la gare
terminé maintenant ce pas de rush des
passages dit on va prendre train et hop
y a plus besoin ne rien dire si ce n'est
le numéro du quai parce qu'évidemment il
sait pas lire contrairement à ce que
disent les gens mais comment ils
feraient pour vous donner le numéro du
bus alors dans l'ain faut quand même le
dire
et puis voilà mais il a des obsessions
si vous un ballon c'est fini le lâche
plus il a même inventé un jeu le freeze
ball cirque il prend le frisbee dans la
gueule est ici tout est bien je peux
vous dire que s'il était avec la nati on
ferait des meilleurs résultats
et puis il avait l'obsession donc
impossible d'ouvrir une bouteille devant
lui alors je vous raconte pas à 10h30
quand vous vous voulez vous en faire une
dernière avec les copains faut toujours
qu'on a un qui se dévouent pour sortir
le chien
et puis ce qu'est ce que j'ai peut-être
encore oublié de vous dire c'est que ce
qui crée aussi un lien quand même assez
particulier par rapport aux autres
chiens en plus que ceci est complètement
un peu fou affectant fond j'aime bien ça
je crois c'est qu'on va ça c'est tout
les déficients visuels qui ont un chien
mais c'est qu'on peut aller partout avec
ses chiens
on va aller à l'intérieur du magasin
juste le nez hauteur des salles ami
génial on va pouvoir aller même dans un
hôpital il a droit de rentrer dans tous
les lieux publics
alors évidemment que ça crée une
certaine proximité certains en abusent
curieusement ça aussi ça m'énerve quand
accompagnée d'une personne voyante
on va au cinéma avec son chien ou un
même ancien c'est mes yeux je les laisse
par la maison eh ben c'est pas lui qui
va faire le 2 description mais lui il en
prend plein les oreilles
alors moi j'aime qu'on respecte son
chien on partage sa vie on appose pas la
sienne et puis ben voilà maintenant il
ya une dernière étape et
qui se profile pour opus que je vous ai
dit qu'il avait 11 ans et demi et à 12
ans obligatoirement il va devoir prendre
sa retraite et normalement il devrait
partir dans une dernière famille
d'accueil pour y finir ses jours
et j'ai bien dit normalement parce que
moi je peux tout à fait comprendre que
si on a une vie extrêmement active ça
soit compliqué de gérer un chien un peu
vieillissant genre carpet comme là je
peux comprendre que si on a perdu
l'habitude de faire les déplacements
uniquement avec sa canne ce soit un
petit peu compliqué de passer oui voilà
illustre bien voilà ça c'est un petit
peu compliqué de d'envisager de refaire
des trajets soldes c'est extrêmement
stressant mais moi je t'ai mon chien le
mettre au rebut comme un vieux machin ça
c'est pas possible
alors j'ai pas si j'étais dans le thème
mais ce que je peux vous assurer c'est
que nous vieillissons ensemble et
ensemble jusqu'à ce que la mort nous
sépare
ce sera nos deux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]